so many of you will have watched my
video symbolism and propaganda
by now on my channel it's become one of
my most watched videos
and i see a lot of commenters talk about
the problem
noticing in the stories these strange
figures of you know the
the woman who beats all the men up and
humiliates them
and i see a lot of people complain about
it but i don't see a lot of people
understand
why it is that this is happening what
mechanism
is bringing about this type of narrative
and so i thought that it would be a good
idea to go into
understanding the relationship between
hierarchy the desire for equality and
how this desire for equality
actually leads to inversion to upside
down behavior and so hopefully
we can go through a few stories i can
try to explain it to you as
much as i can
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
now our culture is obsessed with freedom
we freedom is one of the main qualities
ever since
the enlightenment this idea that men
should be free that people should be
free
that they should not that hierarchy
itself is
dubious the notion that something that
is above you
will necessarily be tyrannical will
necessarily
uh show that show itself as imposing
order
and doing it violently or through abuse
and so
of course this is possible this has
happened
numerous times in history but it is not
the only way that things can lay
themselves out
and so on top of the idea of freedom we
really do have this notion of equality
that equality is the main value let's
say that
that we hold on to now equality is a bit
of a problem
because equality is is something which
ultimately doesn't end up meaning much
because when we say that two things are
equal
each thing has an innumerable amount of
qualities
you know and so what do we mean when we
say that they're equal
are they equal in value monetary value
are they equal in strength
if you're talking about two people
intelligence or strength or
you know the capacity to hide or the
capacity like whatever we have
an innumerable amount of capacities and
so when we talk about people being equal
this is very problematic of course in
the united states they have the notion
that people are equal under the law
which is already a better solution to
the problem of equality
but usually when people think about it
in you know in terms of their philosophy
or
let's say they're just taken for granted
values they
really have this notion that people are
equal or that
different groups or different people
that they're equal this is of course
mind-numbing to the extent that it it
prevents you to think
and what it does is it also prevents a
very simple
truth which is that we are all
participating in different hierarchies
there are all kinds of hierarchies going
around us we are all engaged in them
and most of the time in each aspect of
our life and in each aspect
of our being we are somewhere in some
kind of hierarchy
we have people below us and we have
people above us
and we
when we have this idea of freedom this
notion of
of the the free person we we can
kind of understand the satisfaction
which comes from being above being on
top
winning all this stuff we kind of
understand it in this kind of cult of
the individual
individual we also have this cult of the
winner and of the individual who
succeeds and so we can kind of
understand the satisfaction of rising
in a hierarchy and becoming the top of a
hierarchy but what people
struggle or at least deny more
normally deny is the satisfaction which
comes from
actually submitting yourself to a higher
level
in a hierarchy and i know that people
are going to be watching this
and just me saying that is going to
create a kind of friction in them
that i would even suggest the idea that
we get
great satisfaction from submitting
ourselves to
something to someone which is higher in
the hierarchy
but i would say that if you if you have
that feeling in you
it's really because you're denying
reality and so what i'm going to do i'm
going to point to a few stories
so that you can see that everybody has
that desire um in popular culture we
still have
some of uh we still have tropes of
this satisfaction of submitting yourself
to something which is above you
um the main the main trope that you can
imagine is
for example the knight who looks for a
king a king that is worthy
so that the knight will give service to
that king we also have the trope
of the student in kung fu movies for
example
the trope of the student who is looking
who's yearning to find
a master and submit themselves to
a master one of the reasons why people
liked
the first star wars movie so much was
the fact that you have this
this kind of irascible luke character
that can't find his way that is kind of
kind of hungry kind of looking for
meaning and when he finally meets
uh ben um obi-wan he is able to become
his apprentice and that relationship it
can be fraught can
be uh can be frustrating but you can see
we find great satisfaction in actually
seeing
a student get put in his place by
the master one of the best versions of
this
this story was in the karate kid where
you know the
the the young man comes to this karate
master and the guy says he's going to
teach him
and at first it looks like the karate
master is actually abusing
the young man he's forcing him to paint
his fence to wax his cars
and he's kind of doing this and then he
gets so frustrated and he's like well
when am i going to learn karate you know
you're teaching me all this stuff it's
useless it's pointless you're making me
do all your chores
what am i going to learn and then you
have this moment where the master puts
the student back
in his place as he is demonstrating to
the student
that everything that he has done was in
order to elevate
the student okay so there's extremes
extreme
extreme satisfaction in in finding that
and
like i said this whole idea of a knight
who submits to a king
you can also see it in stories about
coaches you know all these movies that
have a team ragtag team and finally at
first they don't listen to the coach
and the coach finds a way to bring them
together and to listen to
what the coach is directing them to do
and then they win the
championship something like that but the
importance is to understand
the great satisfaction that we find in
seeing people
submit themselves to a higher authority
now it's really important
to be able to acknowledge that and to
understand that it is something that we
are all
searching for that we all have a desire
to submit of to submit ourselves to a
worthy authority
to something which is above us which is
worthy which is worth our
our attention which is worth our
submission and ultimately what that is
is really pointing us towards the whole
idea that we need to be submitted
to god that we need to be uh that we
need to put ourselves below god
and that actually brings the greatest
satisfaction
and we see it in the bible that every
time the someone
you know even saint paul talked about
being freeing yourself from
sin but when you free yourself from sin
you do it in order to submit yourself
to god to become a slave to god so that
you you're actually submitting yourself
to the most
worthy thing when we have this idea that
you can somehow
free yourself and just be your own
person we are deluding ourselves
we are we are living in an illusion
illusionary world
and what happens when we do that when we
have this idea of the
the kind of self-fulfilled individual
the individual who is his own god or who
is his own
the own summit of his hierarchy what
ends up happening
is the the the satisfaction that we get
from watching someone submitting or
participating in
in the submission of one thing to a
higher thing will
end up coming back in very strange and
disturbing ways
and it's going to be inevitable and we
can see that in the modern world the
ultimate trope
has been the trope of the underdog the
underdog has been a way
to on the one hand uh signal
that we don't believe in hierarchy that
hierarchy is somehow evil
that that this idea that there's a team
that's really really good and a team
that's really bad that somehow there's
something wrong about that
and to watch the lower part rise up
and ultimately submit the higher one
is something that we have we despite our
desire for equality
that we find uh acceptable that we can
we allow ourselves to to find
pleasure to find satisfaction in
watching something which was below
rise up and submit what was above
and the reason why we have that
satisfaction
is like i said because the this the
desire to
watch that the desire to participate in
that is in us
it is a part of being in the human
world it is a part of being human to
want to submit yourself
to something above you um and so
what do you do when you have this this
this notion of equality you have to find
you have to find strategies in order to
give people that satisfaction
while at the same time denying the very
structure
so it creates all these very weird
things now the underdog isn't so bad
because there are traditional uh
versions of these stories of underdogs
who kind of rise up and then take
take power but as the that way of
thinking accelerates and takes up more
and more room in our society
what we end up seeing is stranger
versions of that
very strange versions of that and so
imagine that you're making a commercial
and you want to use that satisfaction
people are doing this unconsciously
hopefully to the let's hope that they're
doing it somewhat unconsciously
you want to use that satisfaction you
want to use the
showing of something being submitted
something being
put back in its place and you
you you want to bring that out in the
person you're
making the commercial for now in a world
where you have preached
equality equality equality there is only
one way to
do it which seems ethical and the only
way to do it
is to show the lower party
submit the higher party and so if you
have a
situation and we've seen it so many
times in commercials where
some person shows up the other person it
now will ultimately always be
a woman who shows up a man and why
because
it because we have the desire to see
that relationship but we also want to
deny that relationship we want to
to affirm a kind of equality so the only
way to do it
is through inversion and that is how
upside down
behavior starts to become prominent it
it doesn't become prominent
right away in a desire to invert it
becomes prominent
in the desire to equalize and in that
desire to equalize
it will inevitably inevitably lead to
inversion and so that the same thing
will
happen in if we don't attend to that and
we don't realize that there are
honorable ways
to show this you know like i talked
about the the student and the master who
learns from the master
you as you discover that the master's
harshness towards the student
is there in fact to help the student
become better you see that in tropes
sometimes in movies
where there is a military and you see
the really really harsh commander
who's super tough on his on his men but
then you realize that he's doing it to
help them
and that he's actually willing to
sacrifice himself for his men if push
comes to shove
and he's doing it to raise his men up so
that they be ready for what
is waiting for them and we like i said
we find great satisfaction in that
but then if we if we're not attentive
and we let
that pattern in our kind of come
unconsciously in us
then we have and and especially if we're
declaring equality
then we have the figure of the
disturbing figure of the dominatrix
which appears
everywhere in culture and it's kind of
creeped in it is really important to
note
that both marquis de sade and saser
mazak
the two authors who gave their each of
their name to sadomasochism
were both children of the enlightenment
even though people like stephen pinker
would say that they were the counter
enlightenment
nonetheless they are really born out of
the same type of revolutionary movements
which gave rise to enlightenment
thinking and liberalism in general
connecting this to my video on symbolism
and propaganda
it is at absolutely not a coincidence
that the character of wonder woman
was born exactly in these types of
relationships
and you can even understand the very
disturbing
ascent of the pattern of of cuckolding
this notion of people who want
or desire to to see their spouse cheat
on them
uh is that problem is the problem
of somehow thinking that there is a
something wrong with the relationship
of a man and a normal relationship of a
husband and a wife
and a man and a woman but still wanting
to see that play out
despite your desire to be equal the only
way for it to come about
is to give to the exterior to give to
the
to the stranger so that the stranger
will
enact that desire that you have in you
which is actually
a normal which comes from a normal place
which come from a normal desire to see
that relationship play itself out and so
i think it's really important to
understand that as we're watching
culture
and to understand the mechanism of
inversion and it's not just that we look
and we see the inversion
it's that the the very desire like
the very mechanisms of democracy and and
democratic
notions and the very desire to have
everything be equal
ends up being what brings about the
inversion
and so i hope that this has been helpful
to help you understand how
this works and as we work towards
bringing back those natural desires in a
normal way
hopefully it will at least help you be
attentive to that when it pops up
in your own mind and in your own uh
in the own way in which you find
satisfaction in seeing that
that dynamic play itself out so thanks
again everybody and i will see you
soon if you enjoy the symbolic world
content there's a lot of things you can
do to help us out
if you're not subscribed please do uh go
ahead and share this to all your friends
if you can get involved in the
discussion
we have a facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects
i will put all those links in the
description and also if you
can please support us financially by
going to my website
www.thesymbolicworld.com
support and i also have a patreon and a
subscribe star so thanks again and i
will see you soon